up to 76 percent of people they lay on
their death beds with the exact same
regret they lived in mediocrity they're
like i wish i would have taken certain
chances i wish i would have faced my
fears and went left instead of right but
i chose to be complacent i chose to let
fear stop me from living the life that i
wanted to live and knew i was capable of
doing it just was too scary for me to do
for the people that are watching you
will see that i'm back in my usual
setting i'm back in the uk
you'll also notice that i'm
hand-holding a usb microphone uh and
everything's just a little bit different
that's because i've been slowly fisted
by british airways over the last 24
hours i left austin about 24 hours ago
um two hours late got to london heathrow
that flight left another hour and a half
late neither of my bags arrived and then
i've just got one bag and thankfully in
that one bag is this usb microphone
i've been able to sort of piece together
this very sort of rough-hewn way of
putting stuff but the show goes on
corey that sort of [ __ ] doing okay
you're [ __ ] professional correct i've
extracted british airways from my my
back passage and now we're going to
record a podcast
i'm glad your rectum is clear let's
[ __ ] go yes let's [ __ ] go man so
you are somebody that's transitioned
from being a therapist to now being a
coach and one of the things that i find
that's interesting about that is the
fact that you've obviously dealt with
people that was
subclinical i think is the term so
people that were suffering with uh
issues getting them from um
illness to
wellness rather than wellness to high
performance
um and
what
i'm very very interested about is what
the common challenges are that you found
that high performers deal with that you
were never dealing with with your
previous clients when you were working
clinically and you were getting people
from some sort of um
social anxiety disorder depression
whatever it might be to get them back to
the normal world what is it that the
high performers are dealing with that
you didn't see and also what are the
similarities between the two
yeah so
back when i did therapy
you know therapy is all about
dysfunction right so helping somebody
overcome clinical depression or panic
attacks things like that
so before you can really flourish or
start to tap more into your potential
you have to deal with that baseline
functioning level of [ __ ] first right
because if you are
you know acutely suicidal or like i said
if you're having panic attacks so bad
you can't leave your house
there's
i mean your ceiling for potential is is
pretty low
right so that's where a lot of therapy
is about is how can we just help you
function period to get you out the door
and to just go to like a regular nine to
five or just do you know just basic
functioning [ __ ] right
with a lot of high performers they may
may struggle with like mood symptoms
occasionally right
or they may have anxiety everybody has
anxiety to some extent in some
situations but it isn't necessarily
crippling right so with a lot of the
people that i work with and with
coaching in general it's much more about
the assumption is you you already
function pretty well what you need is
these small tweaks to really optimize
okay so you know sleep diet and exercise
those are probably pretty dialed in your
stress management is probably relatively
dialed in so at this point it's like
okay
what do you need that just that little
bit extra that edge to really go further
faster that's really that the main
distinction is that they're just they're
at a higher level of functioning overall
what are the commonalities tell me the
commonalities between high performers
because everybody looks at the guys that
go and get coaching from people like you
and they think well their problems may
be very different to mine uh but
increasingly as i've spent time around
people that are super high performers i
realize that a lot of people's issues
they scale up they might get bigger and
the um
consequences of them messing up might
become larger but the problems tend to
usually fall into similar sort of
categories
yeah and you know i heard this this
quote the other day
new levels new devils or different level
different devils sort of deal right so
like as you level up you
new problems kind of come your way right
on a base level we all kind of want the
same thing right like we want connection
we want to feel that we matter and we
want to do something that on some level
is meaningful or fulfilling for us right
so whether you are
you know so like you know we can go into
my story you know at some point but like
you know i grew up on like welfare like
food stamps public housing you know and
again like in america we don't have free
health insurance right so the fact that
i had free health insurance meant i was
poor as [ __ ] right
and like so you would think oh well you
you're from this like lower echelon of
society where people they can't even
think ahead of you know they they don't
want the same things as as
multi-millionaires
they do
they may not believe it's possible but
most of us want the exact same things
it's just
what that looks like for each of us may
differ right but again we all want
connection we want fulfillment we want
to matter
and that's what ultimately i i've seen
that we all strive to achieve in some
form or fashion
what about when you're speaking to
people that are at the absolute peak of
their game
what is it that they're coming up
against overall because you know those
people fundamentally what they want is
tomato to feel like they're contributing
to a project that they care about and so
on and so forth but what about the
the the fears
or the doubts that those people have do
they fall into into common buckets as
well the sort of inner monologue the
texture of the environment that their
mind goes through
yeah so
this kind of gets into what i call the
four horsemen of fear right so
the the four most common limiting
beliefs that people struggle with right
fear of failure we we're all familiar
with that right and this is one of those
things where no matter how much you've
achieved that fear doesn't necessarily
go away it changes right like i've i've
worked with people again tens of
millions of dollars of you know millions
of youtube subscribers all these other
things
and one of the things you hear from so
many people is it's almost like the
exact same phrase they say i'm afraid
it's just all going to go up one it's
just all gonna collapse one day
right so i'm gonna go up and smoke like
all of a sudden one day
i'm gonna be left with nothing
and like logically that that isn't gonna
happen right because like even if all of
your you know your your accounts just
went tits up you still have what's in
your bank account you still have the
skill set right it's highly unlikely
that you're going to just be [ __ ] the
rest of your life even if all of your
businesses today collapse
right but that's the sphere right well
i've got you know 20 different income
streams and this and that but what if
tomorrow it all fails
a lot of people struggle with that one
another big one is is fear of
uncertainty right
this whole idea of which path is right
for me which decision should i make
right well i don't know if this if you
know with delegating i don't know if
this person can handle these
responsibilities right which direction
should i take my company
so that's a huge one right is this fear
of uncertainty so what happens with a
lot of people is
instead of so they're at a fork in the
road right so instead of risking making
the wrong decision they just sit down
and make no decision they become
complacent they stagnate right that's a
big issue a lot of people struggle with
another one is fear of ridicule
right so what will other people think or
say how will people react how will my
audience react
right um until they you know look with
with lower level people who aren't as as
high achievers if they haven't achieved
success or anything yet a lot of times
the fear is what will my friends and
family think right after you build a
brains you're not as concerned with that
um
so a lot of times people stay small
right like you've talked about embracing
your weirdness and things like that
right so this whole idea of
um you know i i don't want to risk
ridicule so i'm just going to be as
normal as possible be as basic and just
you know mediocre as possible to avoid
you know that negative reaction from the
public
but the biggest one that people aren't
aware of that holds so many of us back
is actually fear of success
right you think cory why the [ __ ] would
i be afraid to achieve the thing that i
claim to want
and for so many people
if you haven't achieved major success
whatever that means to you
most of us see success as a binary thing
of before and after
if you've never achieved major success
the only version of you that you know is
pre-success
right
so you drag your feet you over
complicate you self-sabotage to prevent
you
from from achieving success
because a lot of us think that well once
i achieve success i'm going to change
right what if i lose my ambition
right what if i become a completely
different person right one of the people
i worked with he's a web 3 founder and
he's like look man i've been the
underdog my entire life
what happens if i actually achieve this
and i'm no longer that underdog what if
in my in my niche i'm given too much
authority to where my word carries way
too much weight i am afraid that you
know the whole idea of power corrupts
i'm afraid i won't be able to to handle
that level of responsibility
and and sway
how do i deal with that
so that's a huge fear a lot of people
really struggle with
so they say they want certain things but
they
not even actively but they sort of like
subconsciously
self-sabotage to prevent them from
facing these things that they're deeply
afraid of so those are the things that i
see a lot regardless of of of how high
of an achiever people are the most
common limiting beliefs all kind of fall
into one of those four those four
buckets
yeah i i've spent a lot of time around
some really competent people i was at
michaela peterson's wedding this weekend
and the table i was sat on was
me
uh jordan peterson caa agent re michael
mallis douglas murray just coming off
the back of a new york times and sunday
times best seller and amazon number one
bestseller rob henderson who's like the
hottest thing in social psychology at
the moment and two other people that
were fascinating as well and one of the
things that i realized is i was having a
conversation with these people
they have a lot of self belief
and
i can't work out whether the self belief
came before the success or the self
belief was driven by the success um but
i get the impression certainly from
having spent time with some of them
douglas especially
he
is so certain of his capabilities
from years and years of iterating on
what he does and this may have always
been that but certainly from iterating
millions of reps right millions of words
that he's written throughout his career
five columns a week at a thousand words
per column for the new york post
america's longest running newspaper and
for
the spectator in the uk and you know
huge publications
and he
simply doesn't have any of these four
horsemen
i believe that he would be pretty open
and honest he may have had them in the
past they may creep up every so often
but it's not the sort of crippling
inertia that it causes a lot of people
to have and
i wonder whether you find
many people that have
one of them or whether most people have
either all of them or none of them
so some people there's typically one
that sort of rises to the top
but for a lot of people that actually
cycles right so like as you're going up
and you're achieving success and
and a big
caveat to all of this is these fears
tend to kick in when we're doing work
that we deeply care about right um
because one of the one of the people
i've worked with they said well when i
had my job like i don't i wasn't really
afraid of any of this like none of these
fears really kicked in it's like yeah
because if you don't connect with your
work
these fears don't really kick in as much
right you're just you're kind of going
through the motions right why would you
fear failure about something you don't
care about exactly right and so it's
this idea of the the the more you're
doing work that resonates with you the
more likely these are going to come up
at some point but different ones may
come up at different points right so
you're saying with this guy he's he's
he's seasoned right like he's been
through all this [ __ ] before but more
than likely as he was coming up he did
struggle with these and as he found ways
to deal with them to conquer them they
like that kind of became like a voice in
the back of his head like way back he
kind of muted it right rather than
screaming at him
but no that's a super good point because
like with with this fear
a lot ultimately we fear the unknown
right
with any kind of fear right what are
people going to say what if i fail what
if i change
but once you face this fear you realize
once you make the unknown known
you realize that it really wasn't as bad
as you had made it out to be
right so then the next time that fear
comes around you're like listen
[ __ ] i've already dealt with
this right like because even if i fail i
know i can recover even if people don't
like what i did i know i can recover
right even if i succeed i know how i can
stay humble and and keep you know
grinding it out and keep this this level
of achievement that i know that i'm
capable of having
so that's probably i would assume the
transition the transformation he's went
through right i'd love to hear more
about his story
yeah it's
it's very strange to look at these guys
that are super super competent now
and
i think a lot of the time one of the
challenges we have as
younger
guys and girls listening to people like
your rogans and your petersons and your
sam harris's and your whatevers
and looking at them to model our
behavior off is that the realizations
that they've come to now they're kind of
shouting down from on top of a mountain
that they've walked up one step at a
time and ali abdullah mutual mate of
ours said a really really good idea that
you want to be teaching somebody that's
two steps behind you not 10 steps behind
you because when you're 10 steps ahead
you can't remember the challenges that
you had all that time ago you know if
you're at the top of the mountain as
somebody that's lectured in front of
students for
three decades
how much really can you resonate with
someone that's got a fear of public
speaking a genuinely you can resonate
with them conceptually but you don't
actually know what it feels like it
wasn't it wasn't last year right and i
think that
that's just something that i'm
increasingly sort of trying to put a
filter on when i'm hearing people
whether it's investment advice from
warren buffett or
lifestyle advice from jocko willink or
something like that that that's
something that they've arrived at
and works for them at this stage of
their life with this degree of
realization with this amount of
experience under their belt etc etc
but that wasn't the route that they took
to get to where they are and sometimes i
think that the path that people say is
where they're at now
they believe is a more expedient way to
get there but perhaps the long way
yeah perhaps you have to take the
stairway to mount olympus perhaps you
can't take the elevator perhaps you have
to do this step by step by step and um
maybe earning your stripes by getting
through ridicule and fear of failure and
uncertainty and success and stuff like
that
maybe those are the
trials and tribulations that you've got
to go through in order to get there
well exactly right like we all have to
kind of earn our way right and that's i
mean that's the issue you see all the
time online is like all these [ __ ]
hacks like life hacks psychology hacks
and here's how to just you know [ __ ]
one two three your way to success in you
know two weeks or whatever you know six
pack abs in 10 days all this [ __ ]
right because people want the results
without the putting in the work right
and that's the thing is
one you have that a lot of people
looking for these hacks and these
shortcuts and then getting disappointed
when they don't work
but even when you when you're talking
about somebody you know like jordan
peterson jacqueline all these other
people who
are proof that it works and they know
what they're talking about right and
they've built this huge following of
people who because they they're they're
trustworthy
right
but you know like i'll take jakka right
jaco
you you know what joku is going to say
right like back in the day you had those
you know wwjd bracelets right like it's
it's that [ __ ] now with jack are like
what would jacob do what would jacob say
right you know what jacob would tell you
to do
but knowing and doing are two different
things
so just because somebody like like jocko
or dr jordan peterson or somebody tells
you exactly what you need to do which is
the correct [ __ ] answer
until you own that until you actually
put that [ __ ] into practice it doesn't
[ __ ] make a difference
and that's the huge issue with with
anybody with any modicum of success is
like look i ate [ __ ] i grinded in
obscurity for [ __ ] years right and
then i got to where i'm at or then i
achieved this
and that's just that's the the [ __ ]
reality is you have to go through that
period
of just eating [ __ ] and grinding
to get to the same [ __ ] place the
same answer that somebody gave you five
ten years ago like think of all the [ __ ]
that you and i were told in our early
twenties that it took us until our early
thirties to be like [ __ ] that was right
yep yeah it's like you hear a lesson and
then over time like a parasite it gets
inside of you and then stares out
through your eyes and tells you that it
was correct all along um
there is no way i think to
expedite
believing something right you need
context you need um stress testing in
real life you need buy-in you don't get
that from just hearing it you know
if all it took was the pithy aphorism
tweet to tell you what to do everybody
would be a millionaire because how to
get rich without getting lucky
from naval
has existed for forever right and it's
the almanac of naval ravicon's one of my
favorite books okay well why is it that
i can't just take this set of
instructions and then lead my life off
the back of it was
it's because
i need to believe it enough to motivate
myself to make the behavior change i
need to work out what that strategy
means in terms of how i apply that to my
own life you know there's so many layers
of filtering through this stuff and i do
think that this is one of the reasons
that simple instructions like jordan
peterson's clean up your room they
resonate a lot because you go well it
actually it's something that you can do
right now today in front of you and
maybe it's symbolic and and downstream
from that good stuff happens
but you don't really need much context
is the room clean or is it not clean you
know you understand what a clean room
looks like and what an unclean room
looks like crack on
the ones that are more complex the ones
that understand about delegating and
leverage and about how to
help other people to raise you up and
network all that stuff very difficult
to to bring into your own life so yeah i
think i think that when we're looking at
the solutions that people give us
it's very easy to say you idiot you knew
this you knew this already and you
continue to not take the advice
and yet you also need to give yourself a
little bit of a break because that's
literally how everybody works if it was
a case if it was simply the case that
the person who had the most information
was the most successful the person that
reads the most books would be the
richest on the planet that's not the way
it works it's about
taking stuff in it's about understanding
the context it's about having the bind
and the motivation that allows you to
then deploy that and it's about working
out how this fits into the broader
framework of your life and how you
operate
but even this [ __ ] conversation you
and i are having right somebody's gonna
watch this episode and then in 10 years
be like [ __ ] cory and chris were right
yes
maybe maybe maybe that'll be us maybe
we'll look back at this episode and go
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] all
right so we've got failure ridicule
uncertainty and success
talk to me about how that relates to
self-sabotaging behavior right because
that's that's a fear that's something
conceptually that's going on emotively
inside of our brains
how does that manifest in people's real
world behavior
yeah so you know for me
most self-sabotaging behaviors are
actually rooted in fear so a lot of
people don't even realize that they have
this fear that's holding them back but
they can't identify their behaviors
right so imposter syndrome
imposter syndrome and perfectionism to
me
are
sort of two sides of the same coin
because
both of these are rooted in a fear of
ridicule you're not a perfectionist
you don't just have like a high bar for
quality okay most people have a high bar
for quality
but your quote unquote perfectionism is
an excuse to not hit publish to not put
yourself out there to not put your
product or service out there right
it's an excuse
because the longer you say oh i'm a
perfectionist i need to tweak it a
little bit more
all that is is doing
as a psychologist we do we do what's
called a functional analysis with with a
behavior all that means is what function
does this serve what purpose does it
have so
the function of perfectionism is to
allow you to continue to avoid this fear
of ridicule because the longer you you
put off hitting publish the longer you
tweak it
the the longer you can avoid it actually
being out there in the open okay
imposter center's the same [ __ ] thing
oh you know people are going to think
that i don't belong in this room or
people are going to think that you know
i'm wrong or i don't know enough
okay and
either they do or they don't if they do
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] and they're not
in your corner and why the [ __ ] would
you respect somebody or seek approval
from somebody who's a [ __ ] bag
or they're not going to think that
because they're going to understand
either you're new or they're there they
want to build you up because they've
been in your same shoes like that's the
other thing
because like i remember when i was in
grad school
we did this and again i originally went
for therapy so we did this out this
outreach event for people experiencing
homelessness so this was in like west
virginia like rural appalachia in
december it was cold as [ __ ]
and we were doing it out back in this
church
so people experiencing homelessness they
would come in they would get like a
medical checkup they would get clothes
food whatever it was the school of
psychology medical school all these
other schools right of health
professions
so all these people were there fighting
for their [ __ ] lives right like it's
sub-freezing temperatures and they don't
have a house and i'm like look i get
that they're here for a medical check-up
or for clothing or whatever what the
[ __ ] am i here to do these these people
do not need deep breathing techniques
they're fighting for their [ __ ] lives
okay
so i went up to two of my my supervisors
who between them had like 50 years of
experience i was like look
when does this feeling like i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing go away
and they were like we'll let you know
right
from that day literally from that
[ __ ] day i never had imposter
syndrome again because i'm like nobody
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
so
using that is all i have imposter
syndrome that's a [ __ ] excuse
that is allowing you to avoid facing
your fear of ridicule
so like those are two that i see all the
time right
or i see people like oh yeah just i
really struggle with procrastination no
you [ __ ] don't
you know what you need to do you are
perfectly capable of doing that when
there's a deadline
right i hear people you know like
friends and [ __ ] all the times like oh
you know at work i'm really high
functioning but then in my personal life
or trying to do this side hustle thing i
just i can't i keep procrastinating
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] excuse
what the [ __ ] are you afraid of
that procrastinating is allowing you to
avoid
right because if you're ultimately what
a lot of times is people are afraid of
failure well i'm afraid it'll fail so as
long as i just drag my feet long enough
i don't ever risk failure because i
never put anything out there
right so like these are some of the most
calm and self-sabotaging behaviors you
see from people and it isn't the
behavior the behavior is a symptom what
the [ __ ] are you afraid of right so
anytime i start to see like myself that
i i'm seeing that i'm dragging my feet
or i'm over complicating something or
i'm taking on too many projects i say
hey
how might this be rooted in my fear what
the [ __ ] might i be afraid of that this
is allowing me to avoid
because the sooner i can pinpoint that
the sooner i can start to take action to
to break down this fear to to try to
overcome it in some way because once
that fear isn't holding me back as long
like
once
i rob that fear of its power over me
that behavior that self-sabotaging
behavior no longer serves a function
because i'm not afraid to face that fear
so then that [ __ ] goes away
i think you're right about
procrastination and the linking with
some of this stuff i would say that
there's definitely times in my life and
in the people that i've worked with
who are struggling with procrastination
simply due to a lack of focus or bad
habits or ease of distraction so i don't
think that this is necessarily the only
reason procrastination i don't think
only ever comes from fear
exactly but
perfectionism is procrastination
masquerading as quality control
that's what i see a lot of the time that
people are scared of shipping their work
and the way that they can inoculate
themselves from failing publicly is by
assuring their failure privately it
means that nobody ever actually has to
see
them potentially fall flat on their face
and the way that they can stop that from
happening is by never actually going out
under the stadium floor
and
that's something that's very difficult
to get past and
a couple of the things that have been
really effective for me
that i can reflect on with this show
because that is me man i spent
six months
vacillating about how i was going to
start the show on when i was going to
start in what the name was going to be
and all of this stuff
and then once you get past that first
little thing
the momentum continues to carry you
forward a couple of the things that i
found that have been really effective
for me in terms of continuing to keep me
accountable and to not allow myself to
slip back into that is to have a regular
cadence that i do the work at so
modern wisdom episodes go out monday
thursday saturday every single week they
have done for two and a half years now
before that it was monday thursday and
before that it was every monday so i
built that up over time the first year
was one a week the second year was two
weeks and from the third year onwards it
was three a week i built that up slowly
over time i also had external
accountability if i if i don't put an
episode up
i'm gonna feel like the audience is
saying well hang on a second like knock
knock [ __ ] where's the episode i
was expecting to listen to something
and you're also you've got a sense of
parkinson's law comes in there
and that you've time blocked things off
you need to get it done by a particular
date it's the same reason that people
like me did their university assignments
the night before they were due in
throughout our entire university careers
um the same thing happens with my
newsletter so i wanted to start a
newsletter i'd been told for ages that
it would be a good idea own your
audience have direct access to them send
them stuff that's interesting and blah
blah blah
and i've never written regularly before
ever two years ago it's about this week
actually coming up will be newsletter
100 so almost exactly two years and
i had never written anything that was
regular so i did a couple of things
there i made it really short so it's
three minute monday which is three
minutes to read so it's about 900 words
on average which is
takes now around about 90 minutes to
write ish as long as i've prepared some
stuff during the week that i actually
can draw on uh and i did it every week
same day same time i tried to write it
at a similar sort of period it happens
between a friday and a monday when i'm
going to write it
all of that stuff again accountability
externally to the audience a sense of
sort of obligation and almost fear and
embarrassment you don't you can utilize
embarrassment to kind of propel you to
go forward because i don't have to make
up the excuse about why it's not
happened and i've never missed one i've
never ever missed one and i'm
the exact type of person that would be
the sort of person that would miss one
right and
it's it almost blows my mind that there
are other parts of other domains of my
life training right
if i don't have a coach that's looking
after my programming i'll miss sessions
all the time or diet if i don't have
somebody that i'm checking in with with
regards to my macros i'll break my diet
all the time but the few things that
i've stuck to those principles regular
cadence
um build it up over time in terms of
sort of difficulty or frequency
and have
external accountability you know have
something someone some group some
audience that's
there in the back of your mind and you
think
not only do i want to do this but i'm
also going to be a little bit
embarrassed if i don't do it so those
are some of the things that i've used
that have helped me get past
procrastination and the perfectionism
side well that and the uncertainty right
man so
on with like exercise and eating right
right
so many people are intimidated by
getting in shape whether it is you know
well what exercise should i do should i
do you know this you know top down or
like how many reps how much weight all
this other [ __ ] right
what you did it sounds like was instead
of trying to figure like perfect like
find the perfect workout you know
regimen you said i'm just going to
outsource that [ __ ] i'm going to remove
the uncertainty
by hiring somebody just you tell me what
the [ __ ] my workouts are for the week
you tell me what macros i need to hit
and give me some food some diet
templates and i'll plug and play right
so instead of you trying to to face that
fear
of and trying to you know engage in all
these self-sabotaging behaviors which is
what most people do
right of i'm i am uncertain i don't know
what is right for me and they just they
they sit there they spend
forever and a day you know googling [ __ ]
or they just decide to do nothing and
put it off and well around new year's
i'll try it out right into the whole new
year's you know um resolution [ __ ]
you're just like [ __ ] all this
uncertainty you just tell me how to do
it you removed that fear
it's strange to think about one of the
challenges that entrepreneurs have and
and people that are sort of uh solitary
go-getters generally
there's always two problems
the first one being that you have to go
and do the work but the second one that
actually occurs before that being you
have to decide what work it is that
you're going to do
so
it's such an unseen pain of being a solo
entrepreneur or a content creator or
somebody that just wants to go and do
something different and on their own and
forge their own path and you're right
wherever you can just outsource that
stuff right
you're going to need to do that a lot
for yourself so on the things that you
can afford to not do that by getting a
coach or someone to write a program just
do it
that and and the biggest you know
advice i can give with the whole like
creator entrepreneur journey and the
fears that that will inevitably you know
provoke is instead of seeing it as
either i'm going to fail or i'm going to
succeed if you can learn to see it as
more of an iterative process
that takes care of a lot because like
you said like you need to do the work
yourself but you need to figure out what
work is worth doing or you need to
create the content yourself and figure
out what the [ __ ] content do i create
if you instead of seeing it as well
either it's going to be a super success
or a complete failure of how can i
iterate how can i just take that one
[ __ ] step and figure out what is what
data what's the data telling what's the
market telling what's my audience
telling me and slowly iterating from
there
that makes it way more approachable and
allows you to be way more consistent
rather than this pass fail false
dichotomy people make it out to be yeah
especially if you go back and look at
tim ferriss's first episode rogan's
first episode my first episode i'm
recording it in the biggest
loudest echoes room
recording on an old iphone with a blue
yeti in between me and my buddy who's
telling me about how he's gonna row the
atlantic naked this is four and a half
years ago um i i would say that there
are certain things that
if you're if you're getting serious
about something do require a little bit
of time
branding is one of those things because
if you end up having a runaway success
that the show's been significantly more
successful than i ever thought it was
going to be and if i'd locked in a name
that i detested that would be something
that i would struggle with right i
happen to love the brand modern wisdom i
think it's great it does exactly what i
wanted it to do
but i've got other friends that are
content creators who
have kind of created this monster that
they're now sort of in the driver's seat
of some huge locomotive they can't stop
it they can't slow it down they can't
change it anymore and every single time
that they see their own name appear
online they sort of cringe inside a
little bit so i do think that there is a
there is an argument to be made there's
a kernel of truth in look spend a little
bit of time thinking about what it's
going to be but just once you've got
that get to an acceptable level and go
there's this great tiago forte tweet
from a while ago saying um
most people
uh rely on perfectionism because it
enables them to avoid shipping work at a
rate that allows them to know what works
basically procrastination
perfectionism is procrastination
masquerading as quality control and that
the vast majority of people who are very
very high leverage individuals
they
have kind of a rough-edged half-assed
quality to their work because they
understand that polishing something to
perfection is a low leverage activity
the difference between a
95 perfect and a 97 perfect podcast
in terms of the impact it's going to
have on the audience is pretty
negligible but the effort it takes you
to get from 95 to 97 is probably the
same as doing another 95 podcast it's
like a an exponential curve of
difficulty to work out all of those
imperfections you know to remove all of
the clicks to remove all of the vocal t
so one of the reasons why with this show
i've never ever gone through and removed
ticks
likes filler words any of that stuff
tons of podcasters so you can even get
algorithms now to automate that that'll
go through and pull out all of that
stuff so it cleans up your audio one
reason is that i never wanted to have to
rely on that i wanted to walk the
tightrope of that performance myself
because if i was lazy and relied on it i
would never actually build up the skill
to be able to do it without that it's
like singing with auto tune
and then on the other side of that as
well
i think well
how much effort is extra effort is that
going to be for what is it going to add
getting from that 95 to 97 okay well
maybe i i go through and pick it out
individually or whatever i get an
algorithm to do it now well how about i
just do another podcast and and that
really seems to work well and then
you've got complacency as well because
the thing that we haven't talked about
is fear of success and how that
manifests in terms of
self-defeating self-sabotaging behavior
yeah so
so with complacency right for a lot of
people
it's easier to say you don't care
or that you you quote unquote have
enough and i don't mean having enough as
far as like being content right being
content and being complacent are two
very different things being content is
means being grateful for everything that
you have
being complacent means you have chosen
to stagnate and say no this is good like
this isn't actually enough this isn't
actually where i want my life to be
but in order for me to attain the life
that i actually want to have requires me
to face certain fears that i would
rather just stay on this side of fear
rather than pushing past my comfort zone
and actually putting myself out there to
take these risks i would just rather say
no i'm totally fine with my you know
nine to five for 45 years of my life in
the occasional week or two week vacation
once a year because then i'll retire at
65 and then i'll really enjoy life
okay but
statistically you're going to die around
80. so you're going to sacrifice 45
[ __ ] years of your life
to maybe enjoy the last 15.
that's complacency again not for
everybody plenty of people [ __ ] love
their jobs right i'm not demonizing a
normal job but for many people they
[ __ ] hate it
and they know what they need to do
but it is terrifying to actually do
so they decide to say no i'm just going
to lower sort of like my ceiling for
what i'm going to tell myself is
possible and just say no this is this is
good enough for me right that's
complacency for a lot of people
and
what you end up seeing um and there's
this cornell university study that they
did and they found that up to 76 percent
of people
are on their death beds they lay on
their death beds with the exact same
regret which equates to they lived in
mediocrity and now they're on the death
bed they're they're full of regret
they're like [ __ ] i wish i would have
taken certain chances i wish i would
have faced my fears and went left
instead of right
but i chose to be complacent i chose to
let fear stop me from living the life
that i wanted to live and knew i was
capable of doing it just was too scary
for me to do
right so so those are are some of the
the biggest issues like for me
personally why you know i think you and
i we um the whole like memento mori
concept right it's a big thing stoicism
a lot of entrepreneurs
gravitate towards those because it's
super practical but that's a big thing
for me man is
with all these fears right whether
you're afraid of success failure you
know whatever
ultimately one day you're going to
[ __ ] die
right
on that day
what do you want what kind of life do
you want to look back on
right do you want to look back on a
lifetime of regret or do you want to
look back and be like hey i had some
hits i had some misses but overall i
[ __ ] love the life that i lived i
loved that i took those chances i loved
that i didn't let fear stop me i loved
that i worked on myself and pushed
through these self-sabotaging behaviors
right that's a big thing for me
um and i you know at some point we can
get into
my how i almost died last year and how
you know my mentor really kind of took a
a literal term for me
but
but that's the big thing for me it man
is
all these fears keep people from from
doing the work that they're meant to do
and that they are the mo the most unique
person to do that work and to bring that
value to the world
right that's that's sort of like my
whole mission in in life for me
personally is to help people push past
those fears overcome those limiting
beliefs those self-sabotage behaviors so
that they can actually reach the [ __ ]
potential that they're capable of
but have told themselves or society has
told them that they're not
it's so sad when you think about that
the fact that there are people who are
born live and die with fantastic
potential and then
this thing comes in it's it's like a
like a weight or a glass ceiling that
comes down and restricts what it is that
they go to go and do and it's not it
doesn't there's nothing there
you go you had the ability to do all of
this stuff
and and for some reason you didn't get
there
and
that's sad that makes me sad to think
that there's a lot of people for whom
that's gonna be their life i i learned
this story from douglas while i was away
with him in new york and he told it on
the podcast it's so powerful had this
friend who was um one of the editors of
the first one of the first newspapers
that he worked at clive somebody legend
in the publishing and journalism game
and he decided that he was going to
release a play on the west end about
prince charles the entire thing was
going to be in rhyming couplets uh
perhaps
not the broadest audience that he could
tap into and he didn't think that it
even made it past opening night or it
was nobody left including the cast by
the first interval and douglas went up
to his friend and he said
clive what if he you know this seems
like a little bit of a an error and he
was destroyed this guy was like
destroyed by he thought he was really
going to be doing well and so on and so
forth and took us you know how do you
deal with the pain of putting up with
this sort of very public failure on the
west end
he said well
i followed my instincts
and
you know
they may sometimes lead you wrong but
your instincts are the only things that
have ever led you right
what i realized was that
if you allow fear to come in and
tamp down your ability to tap into that
intuition and that instinctual nature
that tells you about very easily tells
you what to do tells you to cross the
street tells you to stay with that
relationship it tells you to change
careers move to a different city
the more that you don't listen to that
the quieter it speaks or the harder it
is to hear and over time you can
habituate doing that less and less and a
lot of people that are very sort of
cerebrally minded and love the cognitive
stuff
they can think themselves into or out of
pretty much anything you you have to be
quite smart
to be able to convince yourself that the
thing that every fiber of your being is
screaming at you to do is not the right
thing to do like you have to actually
congratulations congratulations you've
managed to out think your programming
and your gut
and you've managed to convince yourself
that the thing that it's telling you to
do isn't the right thing to do
but i do think that there's something to
be said for allowing that
instinct to kind of carry us through and
increasingly that's something that i'm
trying to sort of tap into as well look
how how do i get out of my own way
so this and this whole idea of like
metacognition right like
thinking about how you think thinking
about the language that you use with
yourself like your personal narrative
right so like
some people their their personal
narrative is that they're broken or that
they are a victim
regardless of what they've actually
experienced one way or the other right
like
you know back when i did therapy some
people they went through heinous [ __ ]
some of them identified as a victim some
of them identified as a survivor and
that one [ __ ] word difference
completely changed the trajectory of
their lives
right because when you identify as a
victim or you identify as broken or in
some way unlovable worthless helpless
hopeless
that
dictates everything about your life
right we talk about like rose color
glasses or whatever
but when when your internal monologue
when your personal narrative is super
negative and toxic that caps how what
you think about yourself your truth what
is true about your potential what is
true about the world is the world
dangerous what you deserve right if you
don't think you deserve something you're
not going to to reach for it so you
won't [ __ ] get it right but it's you
know this whole idea man is like
i'll take you for an example like you
know you've talked about how you know
you're you you prioritize your physical
health you know you were a model you did
the whole like you know
love island or whatever thing right like
aesthetically you're a handsome dude
right like that is like sort of like an
objective objective thing right i know
it's okay
but here's the thing man
i promise you that if you every day even
just once a day
every morning as part of your [ __ ]
morning routine you looked in the mirror
and you said i am fat i am stupid and i
am ugly i
if you did that every [ __ ] day for a
year at 365th day your truth
quote unquote in air quotes your truth
would be that you are fat stupid and
ugly regardless of your physical [ __ ]
appearance or intellectual capability
and that's some [ __ ] that so many people
struggle with but don't even recognize
that because of the skill of
metacognition of learning to to examine
the [ __ ] thoughts that rattle through
your head because everything that you
are capable of starts inside your
[ __ ] head because if you don't think
you're capable you won't strive if you
don't strive you won't achieve
so everything comes it originates in
your [ __ ] personal narrative and the
thoughts you tell yourself
something that i noticed in myself and
coming from a working-class background
you may be able to resonate with this as
well
um me and a bunch of my friends really
struggle to spend money
i
really really struggle to spend money
i'm trying to work this out at the
moment it's something like the working
class mindset or the the perils of the
working class mindset
and
i had a fantastic start to the year
we've been working me and dean have been
working super super hard on the show and
we had a great few few months of
plays and and ad revenue and
new sponsors and stuff like that and i
haven't bought myself anything in ages
uh so i thought well i'm gonna treat
myself i couldn't get a car in america
because i uh didn't have a social
security number which meant that i
couldn't go and get any finance so i was
like well did they do these electric
scrambler bikes it looks like an old
style cafe cafe racer motorbike but it's
actually just an e-bike that does 30
miles an hour so you don't need a
license you can ride them on uh cycle
paths and they're they're pretty cool
yeah it's like i i have earned this i
spend hours and hours and hours in a
room on my own
researching reading editing publishing
scheduling all of that stuff i deserve
this bought it within two weeks sent an
email saying i i don't just cancel the
order take it back because i for some
there was something about me that
couldn't deal
with the fact that i was doing that
now
today the flight that was partly hugely
delayed i flew business class for the
first time that i'd booked it in advance
and for some reason that felt a little
bit different but there's something
about that working-class mindset what do
you deserve
um
that means that you'll go into the
supermarket even as you're you know
earning a very comfortable wage and look
for the multi-buy deal on the pasta
sauce which will take up five minutes of
your afternoon which you should be
spending working and earning way more
than the saving that you're going to get
on the [ __ ] pasta sauce
but
it's the thing that you'll do
and it's so fascinating i mean do you
find this in yourself you know going
from somebody that
food stamps and and sort of welfare
state stuff to now being somebody with
money is this still a
pervasive element of your spending
habits as well yeah like
and it's also weird for me to like if
it's if it's something for the business
i'm like cool right
well like i don't really fly right now
but like if it's like oh i need to get
some new equipment or i need to do this
or i need to take this new course i'm
like oh three thousand dollar course
[ __ ] it fine it's a business expense
but then if i'm like okay well i can you
know if i'm gonna get like the the
amazon basics shorts
like just to wear around the house or go
to the gym i'm like well [ __ ] okay well
a three pack is this much and a six pack
is is that much like how much am i
actually whatever i'm like i just spent
three thousand dollars or seven thousand
dollars on a [ __ ] course
but i'm i'm quibbling over like
20 cents or five bucks over here there
right like okay well you know this rib
eye at the store is you know 1798 and
then but this package over here is 18.24
like is it really that much more like
it's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
right and like because
whether it's working class or you know
poverty whatever because like growing up
like my parents worked to a certain
point but then like they both had like
significant like medical issues that
that took them out of the workforce
right so
um
for us it wasn't even like you know
oh well you know we're like man i
remember the first girl i dated her
family made like 40k a year right which
is like lower middle class and i'm like
this [ __ ] is rich
because i'm like [ __ ] like we made we
brought in like 12 000 for the year
right and
that sticks with you i think because
that's very formative right like how you
evaluate what something is worth
is is that right and i think you've
talked about this too this whole idea of
if you do client work it's really easy
to devalue yourself and not charge what
you know you're worth
right and so i think for a lot of people
who come from like a lower or like
middle class income threshold
that is something that is really hard to
overcome when you're going out and doing
your own thing building up your business
and and you you achieve a modicum of
success because like this is a thing of
like you're still used to nickel and
diming everything and it's just no man
like i'll struggle with it too it does
get easier i mean there was this one
time where i remember i'd spent at least
a minute
looking at the
working out whether i could justify the
value or the finest range of yogurts in
a supermarket this was like five years
ago and that was a that was a formative
experience talk about strategic learning
opportunity i'll never forget that
staring at these yogurts going
what on earth are you doing you work all
the hours that god sends and you're
terrified of buying the slightly nicer
yogurt um so i think that you're right i
think that
it's probably a combination of a bunch
of different things but it does get
better if there's someone that's
listening that goes [ __ ] that's me down
to a t i i still really struggle to
spend money on myself um a couple of
ways that you can get around that i
think increasingly try to justify things
as facilitating um
your passion or the thing that actually
brings the money in so for me it was
much easier to justify the business
class flight because i knew i had this
podcast with you today like yo if if i
get even if i only catch four hours
sleep on that flight over that means i
can properly do this episode with corey
without looking like a
sleeped over deprived zombie right and
okay well that there we go that
justifies it for me that feels a little
bit better so that's one thing uh and
another thing i think is to realize that
you probably do deserve this like all of
the time that you've spent working all
of the effort that you put in all of the
hours that you do stuff
but i mean i'm saying this to myself as
the guy that just sent back a a
scrambler e-bike the only thing that he
really treated himself to
so far this year okay so we've gone
through
the different horsemen we've gone
through some of the ways that that fear
can manifest in terms of activity
how can people inoculate themselves from
this moving forward what are the
strategies that they can put in place so
that they're going to mitigate these
fears when they come up
yeah so
like i said before ultimately we fear
the unknown so if you can make the
unknown knowable
fear kind of loses it its power over you
all right so fear inoculation for me
it kind of works similar to a vaccine
right and i'm not that kind of doctor
but my elementary understanding of
vaccines is you introduce a little bit
of the bad thing so then you can build
up a tolerance or an immunity to it if
it ever comes around again right so
let's say you're afraid of failure
severe inoculation is okay let's assume
you [ __ ] fail your worst case
scenario actually happens
with that assumption in place what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do how are you going
to recover how can you learn to see it
as sort of like thinking like a
scientist of it wasn't like a a pass
fail necessarily of what does the data
tell me how can i like identify patterns
and what worked and what didn't to take
that and iterate for version two
right because again like it isn't that
you outright failed irrevocably so much
as this one thing
told you that your approach didn't work
for some reason
right so how can you make tweaks how can
you analyze the data and then do a v2
and iterate
if you're afraid of ridicule
assume whatever the [ __ ] you did people
are talking [ __ ] on or you're getting
canceled or some other kind of [ __ ]
right with that assumption in place how
are you going to do damage control how
are you going to get ahead of the
narrative right how are you even
evaluating where this ridicule is coming
from are the people ridiculing you
people whose opinions you give a [ __ ]
about in the first place
most of the time they're not
right there's this you know nipsy hustle
quote you will never be criticized by
somebody doing more than you you will
only ever be criticized by somebody
doing less than you so all these
[ __ ] who are talking [ __ ] are
they just miserable [ __ ] bags who want
to troll and find something to be
offended over or is this an audience
that you actually respect and you care
about if that's the case how can you do
damage control and learn from what
happened
right if you're afraid of uncertainty
let's assume you made the wrong [ __ ]
decision
how can you course correct
right how can you
gain more information to make a better
decision right or let's say you're
afraid of uncertainty to the point you
make no decision so instead of risking
taking the wrong way you you did nothing
and you've stagnated and you made no
progress for five years okay what's
preventing you from making progress what
is
fueling this uncertainty right what is
the minimum amount of information you
need
to move forward to take one [ __ ] step
forward right
this whole idea of just in case versus
just in time learning right so just in
cases you just collect all this
information perpetually right you try to
read 3000 books a year or some [ __ ]
versus just in time is i am actively
building something and i have now hit a
wall because i don't know what to do
next what is the one piece that if i
found this information i can move
forward that's just in time learning so
how can you adopt a just in time
learning mindset
right with with success let's say you
succeed and you lose all your ambition
or you become this super cocky [ __ ]
that [ __ ] nobody likes cool
how can you develop humility who can you
surround yourself with who are other
high achievers who have already achieved
big [ __ ] but continue to push themselves
forward right like you i'm sure the
people you hang out with now are
different than the people you hung out
with in high school or undergrad or
whatever right as you level up your
circle and i don't mean necessarily you
have to find different people but your
circle tends to level up with you right
that's a huge thing with the internet
now like the majority of people i've met
that have have helped me in you know as
an entrepreneur and a content creator or
whatever i've met since december 2020
when i got fired from my [ __ ] job and
other issues prevented me from getting
another job and i was like [ __ ] i got to
learn how to blaze my own [ __ ] trail
and i don't have a business background
my undergrad is a [ __ ] psychology how
do i do this it was the people i met
right so how can you surround yourself
with better people who are humble who
are hungry that can help you level up
and go in the direction you want to go
so no matter what the [ __ ] you're afraid
of there is some way that you can
inoculate yourself against it by saying
okay if this happened how would i
recover because as soon as you realize
that you can recover from any of these
worst case scenarios that worst case
scenario is no longer terrifying it can
no longer hold you back
because you know how the [ __ ] to deal
with it
one of the common challenges i think
people face in situations like this is
that they don't have an adequate support
system around them and role models that
they can look up to especially ones that
are close to them and it's great to have
a role model that you have a parasocial
relationship with right you know jocker
willing or david goggins or someone
who's your hero and whatever but
there's a degree of importance to be
able to have a dialogue with someone
right to see them and to have a
conversation with them even if it's only
over the internet and um
i was having this chat last week with
someone who was asking me about what
what you do
if you don't have any good role models
around you and i realized that i kind of
wanted a lot more positive role models
when i was growing up too and i was
around a lot of people that i really
didn't want to be like
then i realized that that was actually a
really good influence on me like okay i
didn't have many people in the town that
i grew up in that were the sort of
people that i wanted to grow up to be
like
but i had a ton of signals that told me
the sort of things that i didn't want to
do so this is the negative role model of
the reverse role model right
avoiding stupidity can get you a really
really long way in life you can get
really really far by just not having
unforced errors that you continue to hit
into the net over and over again how
many people do you know that got some
girl pregnant that they weren't in a
relationship with or
how many people crashed a car when
they'd had a couple too many beers and
now they're banned from driving and have
got a criminal record on their license
you know like easy things you can avoid
to do and all of these were examples
that i had said to me when i was growing
up so yes it sucks if you don't have a
fantastic role model if you're not in
new york or l.a surrounded by
interesting cool people that can tell
you exactly what you want you know if
you're in the arsenal of virginia or in
the you know the town in the uk with
this highest teen pregnancy rating which
it then lost so it didn't even have that
anymore that was my state we had that
too yeah you're good nice high five so
that
the fact that you don't have that
sucks
but the fact that there are tons of
people around you that are showing you
exactly what you don't want to do
is
equally useful
it genuinely is yes it feels kind of
icky and it's annoying and it's kind of
it's a slimy version of it because you
feel like you're having to sort of
trudge through it's not as inspirational
or aspirational or sort of upwardly
mobile
but it's one hell of a learning lesson
you know that you know the mental model
never multiply by zero that you can take
five hundred thousand times by forty
thousand times by ten times by three
times by zero if you multiply anything
by zero you get zero so you need to
avoid huge failures you need to not be
driving without your seatbelt on you
need to not
get a girl pregnant or get yourself
pregnant when you're 16 years old and
you have absolutely no support system
around you at all like these are things
that are multiplying by zero right
because they completely curtail tons of
options in your life
that's a pretty good signal so reverse
role models aren't as inspirational but
they're certainly very useful
well and just this whole idea of
especially you know when you're growing
up in a toxic environment do you want to
be where these people are
because if you do what they did you will
for better or worse right like this
whole idea of if you want to be
successful do what successful people do
if you want to be unsuccessful don't do
what unsuccessful people do
right so like even like with parenting
right like if you want to be a good
parent
it doesn't actually matter if you have
if you had good parents or or toxic
parents because if you had good parents
do what they did if you had toxic
parents do the opposite of what the [ __ ]
they did
right so no i fully agree like you can
draw inspiration from your environment
one way or the other
but i do and again like i came from that
environment right like you know drug use
and and domestic violence and a lot of
you know [ __ ] up [ __ ] that was just
that was normal for me
right and i had supportive family
members and things but i also had toxic
ones and i had toxic you know all of my
friends growing up are in prison or been
in and out of prison right like i
understand that life
but
between that you know anti-role model or
that reverse role model
mental model but also
you can meet so many people online with
[ __ ] twitter or you know some
whatever the [ __ ] you're yeah whatever
the [ __ ] your preferred platform is man
like
there's this whole idea of like it's not
gated anymore like there aren't
gatekeepers like there used to be
like i have met so many people either in
cohort based courses i've taken
or just through twitter in general and
these are people that you know whether
they're they're major major players you
know quote in the air in the space or
just normal [ __ ] people who are
supportive you can
surround yourself with with a digital
community
like no time before
there's no excuse
as long as you have internet or you just
have access to books or some kind of
[ __ ] regardless of your current
situation i promise you there are ways
for you to learn and grind your way out
of it on some level
i hope that it makes people realize that
that is an option and it does make me
sad thinking about how many people are
in
a place that doesn't support the goals
and dreams that they've got especially
in the uk this is something i've noticed
that's a really big difference between
the uk and the us uk is
like really really good at satire and
taking the piss and making sure that
people's feet are kept on the ground
right
it's great the problem that you get with
that is that it's a tall puppy syndrome
it discourages people from doing
different things now in america you end
up with
blue sky vision you can achieve anything
you want to you've got the american
dream is at your feet and stuff like
that now that's great for encouraging
kids to go and do what they want
especially when they're young the
problem that you have is when they grow
up and they look around at the world and
they say well hang on this
this wasn't what i was promised i was
promised the earth at my feet
and i've got
something else and the delta between
those two is is often painful and i
think that this is one of the reasons
why
the uh sort of victim
culture mentality
doesn't happen quite so much in the uk
because that's kind of already been
beaten out of you as a kid but the
problem that you have with that is that
there's less enthusiasm and
encouragement when you want to go and do
different things so i think that
the blend is between the two and i've
seen this since being in america that
most of my british friends that have
gone over to america have really enjoyed
the culture and that their influence on
the american people around them has been
really good as well because it's brought
them down to earth a little bit and the
americans have sort of given the brits a
little bit of self-belief so that is
great but it does make me sad to think
about the fact in the same way as the
the fears and the limiting beliefs they
constrain somebody's potential and it
kind of isn't really a thing it's not
really something that exists
and yet it's able to restrict what
somebody achieves in life is kind of the
same thing with this lack of
community supportive
sense around them as well you go look
this person could be this
and yet due to no fault of their own
simply by the you know lack of fortune
of the area that they're born in or the
time that they were born another street
that they were born on
they don't have the support that allows
them to
do something that would make them
lead a radically more fulfilled and
different life
on just man
going back to this this personal
narrative idea
the simple sentence of for the simple
belief of
people like me don't do that
right people from where i'm from don't
do x y or z like i i wrote this article
a while ago
this whole idea of so i'm from rural
appalachia like i'm i'm from a town
called lisage west virginia the only
people who pronounce it at least age are
people from there everybody else
pronounces it lesage like some fancy
french [ __ ]
it ain't it's lease age
and i remember growing up
the people who sounded like me
weren't entrepreneurs they weren't you
know doctors
right like those people they spoke
differently right we we talk different
if you want to be successful you need to
speak differently so when i went to
college and i was you know with a
four-year degree i was the first person
in my family with a college degree
before your degree
i actively tried to lose my accent
because i was like well successful
people don't sound
like me like i'm from up a hauler nobody
nobody
sounds like that you're successful so i
actively tried to lose my accent and and
sort of disconnect myself from my roots
from from my home
and what i realized was a lot of the
people that i met
at one there's like there's like a party
where i'll add like a fraternity party
at one point and like all of a sudden
people's accents started coming out
these people are drinking whatever and
we're like holy [ __ ] like you're from
someone someone you know where you're
ready as well dude and everyone's like
holy [ __ ] and we realized all of us had
tried to lose our [ __ ] accents to fit
in
and like slowly i came to terms with
that and like i i i allowed more of my
accent my draw to come out
and and you know the the article kind of
ended with like you know my name is let
me introduce myself my name is dr corey
wilkes i'm an entrepreneur and i say
y'all i'm from up a holler right like
and it's just this idea man it's like
this this i think you and ali abdul
talked about this of having role models
and people who look like you or people
who talk like you that's so [ __ ]
important man and it's it's such a
glaringly missing thing especially if
you want to talk about like men and
masculinity type [ __ ] but
just that idea of like either finding
these these para
role models or you know whatever or just
trying to connect with other people
online i promise you there are other
people who get where you're coming from
who can help support you on the journey
you want to take
it's only since i've been in austin that
i've been around men's groups a lot this
isn't really something i don't know
maybe they exist in the uk but i i i've
never
heard about them or whatever maybe they
exist outside of newcastle which is
where i'm living
um
but yeah you see these men's groups and
i've been to a good few of them now
man you've got some of the most
competent guys who people that have
already retired that live in gorgeous
mansions that spend their days investing
in companies and doing cool stuff
and they still need every single week on
a wednesday for four hours in the middle
of an afternoon they still need their
boys to come around and for everybody to
be kind of calm and and not playing
games and and just
a space that they hold for everybody
else you go what is this is this some
hippy [ __ ] and yet it's the same guys
that are absolute killers uh and
that that was kind of a bit of an eye
opener to me that you see people that
you really wouldn't think would be the
sort of people that would need a
broadly a support group you know
connection yeah connection that's one of
those universal things and we need
connection yeah you wouldn't think it so
yeah man it's it's an interesting one i
um i really appreciate your work i
really appreciate the input that you've
got i appreciate the insight that you
bring as well i like the fact that
you're bridging the the sort of the
clinical with the coaching side too what
have you got coming up anything that you
want to direct people to anything they
should know about
um so i'm actually
finishing up the first cohort of a
cohort based course it's
called intentional life design so it's
all about how do you overcome limiting
beliefs think bigger and and do work
that matters to work that resonates with
you um cohort 2 will probably come out
around late august early september
so i can give you a link for that um
page for people to check it out
otherwise people just follow me either
on twitter my website whatever my my
handle is the same cory wilks id
everywhere
that's pretty much it i appreciate you
cheers man
thanks for having me on man i appreciate
it
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace